hey guys it's Michelle if you're
anything like me you probably have a
hard time stepping away from life and
work to focus on yourself today I hope
that you take five minutes and do just
that this routine is great for after a
stressful day at work or study today
we're going to target the lower back and
hips which hold a lot of tension when
we're under mental stress if you want to
hold any of the poses for a little bit
longer feel free to hit pause just think
into the pose a little bit further as
I'm only demoing each move rather than
doing a full-on routine I usually like
to hold each pose for about 60 seconds
to get a full muscular release but it's
up to you and your body to decide what's
best for you and what you need on this
dress's day so here are some great
stretches to de-stress after a long day
for the next stretch reach your hand
over your head and pull your ear towards
your shoulder you can reach your other
hand out towards the ground for a deeper
stretch Sphinx elongate your lower back
where you'll feel a lot of tension if
you drive a car or sit in a desk chair
for long periods of time
sphynx transitions really nicely into
seal another lower back stretch that
also elongate your abdominals
[Music]
pigeon is a tough stretch to get out the
kinks in your hips which hold a lot of
tension under stress lizard-like pigeon
stretches on the sides of your hips and
hip flexors
[Music]
side straddle is a little bit of an
advanced post but I encourage you to try
it out because it opens your inner groin
and side body which honestly just feels
really good after a long day butterfly
is a great stretch for the inner thighs
groin and knees and removes fatigue from
long hours of standing and walking maybe
hold the pose long enough you'll also
start to feel it in your lower back
lastly Child's Pose is a calming and
surrendering pose to tie up your
stretches to de-stress thank you guys so
much for watching this video and for
trying out this routine if you enjoyed
it please give it a thumbs up and
comment below with what workout you want
to see next I hope that you feel a
little bit less stressed and ready to
take on your day
[Music]